good day everyone and welcome
i'm jack van horn from the university of
virginia and once again please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our
2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege to welcome
our speaker today dr randy golub from
the mccann's
center for brain health at massachusetts
general hospital in boston massachusetts
dr gold earned her phd and her md from
duke university school of medicine
she conducted a residency at the
hospital of san rafael in new haven
connecticut
and her another residency at yale new
haven hospital
and she has um board certifications in
psychiatry
as well as through the american board of
psychiatry and neurology
dr gold was recently elected to the
chair of the organization for human
brain mapping
and serves as professor of psychiatry
and associate director of translational
research and neuroimaging research
program
at massachusetts general hospital she is
a recognized leader in the development
and applications of advanced neural
imaging technologies to understand the
pathophysiology of neuropsychiatric
disorders
including neonatal hypo hypoxic ischemic
encephalopathy chronic pain and
schizophrenia
she is actively working on translating
these advances into clinical
radiological practice to improve patient
care
the use of large-scale imaging
informatics approaches
work in her laboratory focuses on using
clinically acquired brain images from
neonatal
subjects as well as young children to
build age-specific
normative brain atlases of quantitative
tissue metrics
to advance understanding of brain
development in the application of those
normative atlases
to detect abnormalities associated with
hypoxic ischemic encephalopathy
in neonates this approach enables the
detection of subtle anatomical
variations
through the use of machine learning
algorithms and other sophisticated
statistical techniques
the work of dr golub and her team
demonstrates the exciting potential of
leveraging existing
electronic health records data including
clinically acquired brain imaging scans
to yield information on par with
clinical research studies that were
conducted over decades at the cost of
many million dollars
dr gold's lecture today is entitled
clinical imaging informatics in action
extracting valuable knowledge from
archival pediatric brain mri
and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for recording via
youtube if you are joining us by youtube
thank you so much
for your attention today also specific
our specifically selected
2020 2021 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr golum by the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions i will
ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome randy we
are so excited to hear your lecture
today
well thank you jack for that lovely and
friendly introduction and
good afternoon everyone or whatever time
you're watching this
uh it is my pleasure to be here and to
share this
um fairly unique kind of research
with you all i know for those of you who
are in this program
some of you are trained as clinicians
and and certain features of this will be
a little bit more familiar and others
not so i'll
hopefully take the time to help everyone
be on the same playing field to
understand
how this is done and why um in
particular
i'm i'm going to try and make the case
in a way that will be completely
understandable
as to why someone would want to bother
to use the
clinical imaging data that's collected
for secondary research purposes
i'm going to help you to understand what
the challenges are and also show you
some exciting
new developments that are beginning to
overcome
some of those challenges i'm going to
show you at our institution how exactly
we can make this happen
and then by way of sharing the exemplar
work that's being done
with my colleagues help you to have a
real intuitive understanding of what
could be done and its potential
with a you know just a glimpse at what
the future might hold
i just want to take this moment to uh
give a shout out to my friend and
colleague steve piper who
if you notice in this little front
picture here each of these
um this sweet baby's face is made up of
a mosaic of these little
thumbnails of brain image data this is a
sort of a very dramatic
illustration of how much of those image
data we have available to us
to use to do this research and steve is
a master of these things
so i the why part the why part is really
important um
why bother you know you've heard recent
talks i believe jessica turner
spoke with you not too long ago about
the enigma all these different
huge efforts that are being underway
that are being funded to collect
lots and lots of data for the research
community to use
well there's other data also and there
are
special reasons why this data might be
more appropriate for something that
you're interested in doing
so for example if you quickly need to
get a hold of
say 200 000 brain mri scans that you
wanted to be able to extract a
hippocampal volume from
in order to build an ai tool that would
help you to screen for early evidence of
cognitive decline
well this path that i'm going to show
you might be one
you know it's not free and it's not you
know immediate but there is a path to
get that data to work on and in
particular because this is
real world collected in the wild data
the tool that you would develop
using these scans might be more much
more immediately useful to run on the
standard clinical scanners
that are in use in the different
academic healthcare centers
or hospitals you know worldwide and
and as opposed to tools many of which
get developed on the research data
and those early passes really have
limitations to how well they will
operate on this
uh tougher data i should say i'll be
showing you some things about that today
another really important um thing to
consider is what kind of data
from which patient cohort or what kind
of ages are necessary for the work you
want
to do and in in some cases if it's a
rare disease
it may be very hard over the time scale
that you might have available on a grant
or a
you know in your life span to collect
everything on yourself
so there's collaborations but there's
also ways of
acquiring that data through the hospital
archival scans
um and in the case of what i'll show you
today it's that rare data from being
able to get a hold of
information from brand new babies who
typically are not in a hospital having a
brain scan
and while i'll talk today about all
brain mri because that's the domain that
i work in
in fact this workflow this sort of
conceptual frame for what i'm showing
you would be
completely appropriate if you needed a
ct scan if you needed an ultrasound if
you
whatever kind of imaging that you needed
to use
the the workflow
that this data comes in under is an
important concept
uh to understand in terms of uh what you
know you can think of it as your
your experiment of how you're enrolling
your patients you'll see how this
matters
um in the typical clinical workflow a
scan would be
collected because some doctor has a
patient that
they feel needs to have some imaging
done to help them care for their patient
they enter an order a unique accession
number is assigned to that
to identify the study in the patient
it's scheduled
this protocol step is really important
that's where
the radiology department or the other
domain expert will choose
explicitly how the the scan will be
collected
always it's done in with respect to
what is the question being asked of that
patient when the patient arrives
they are brought to the scanner that
information is used to
to label the scan and during the scan
session if the
operator notices uh knew something that
they weren't expecting they might
add or change that protocol by adding
additional scans or if there's a
problem in the system they might repeat
a scan and then those images are
are passed to this archival storage the
picture archive and communication system
the pax which is a very smart database
because it
supports a lot of communications all the
images
are in a file format called dicom those
of you who work with any kind of medical
images
are probably familiar with this standard
it's cool lectures on these topics right
here
and depending on the study they may
already be automatically best done based
on the order that was entered in the
exam that was done
sent for some additional advanced image
processing to feed that information
also back into the packs and then it's
fed into the workflow of the
radiologists who will
read that information read the scans
interpret them and
fill out a report that is then also put
into the medical record
and so people working in ehr data have
access to many of these different
bits they uh accept these images
typically when
a when a clinical informatics
person is working with medical imaging
data what they're really working with is
doing some nlp
on the exam um that the interpretation
that the radiologist
has has provided and not digging very
deeply
into the medical image data itself
so one i wanted to share a force vector
that suggests that this work could be
very
meaningful and continue to be more
impactful over time
as the fields of research imaging and
clinical imaging they're always
interacting with each other as the
quality of the scans
improves through higher temporal
resolution and spatial resolution and
different types of sequences that give
more and more information that's
meaningful about
tissue properties the um the size the
magnitude the amount of data that's
embedded in a scan
continues to grow and so the requirement
to extract as much information out of
that
also continues to grow and so this move
towards more
quantitative assessments with tools that
mine the data
and and then use the information as it's
coming in to help
create more useful information for how
to care for a patient
builds on this informatics
infrastructure and so
the whole field is definitely moving
stronger and in many
supported ways towards this more
quantitative extraction
of meaningful data out of the medical
images
which supports the effort that we're
doing because it kind of makes it easier
to find and work with
and do more with that data and makes the
results that we create on the research
side
gives us a tighter and stronger loop
back up into the clinical into clinical
care
so just a quick digression just to say
that
the these standardized radiology reports
is templated
reporting is also something that is of
value
in that it helps that when a ai tool
quantifying hippocampal volume happens
that the radiologist
has a way to easily and quickly in
insert that information into the medical
record
making the ehr data more and more rich
and easier and easier to use
for research but also enhances the
quality of what is
is available for the clinicians in those
radiology reports when they're making
their decisions for patient care
and so the incorporation of that
additional information
is eased through these structured
reporting so all these different efforts
on these different fronts
kind of are all sort of lifting um
lifting us up
and making it more and more likely and
and more reasonable that this work will
have
a clinical impact and in the end that's
what matters
um so much so so now
coming back from our digression so the
unique challenges if you want to use
this kind of data for your research
um if we look at the parallels in this
domain
you know you might be used to in the
research world
thinking about designing a study where
you would have a standardized
acquisition protocol
you'd be very specific about it and all
the little details of how it would be
how a brain mri scan might be collected
would be
decided in advance you would have maybe
make efforts to send a human phantom
to the different sites to make sure that
they were all calibrated as perfectly as
you could
you go for the best possible image
resolution you carefully screen your
subjects
if you have a patient cohort you use
detailed inclusion exclusion criteria
to select them you carefully match the
healthy subjects on
all the different demographics that
would need to be give you the best
bang for the buck and carefully
comparing your patients to
controls the results you get very
quantitative and standardized
so when we go through a clinical on the
clinical side
we approach it very differently because
as i just taught you
for every time an acquisition happens
it's really
patient-centric it's based on the needs
of the patient and customized to them
and so
you know while there is some systematic
um effort in there because there are
just a sort of a finite number of
protocols and sequences that could be
run
the recipe is uh you know absolutely
tweaked per person
and the and an important issue here
is time versus money so the uh the more
that you
more resolution the higher the
resolution the more detail the more
complete the
net anatomical coverage all of those
things mapped taking longer time
not only to acquire but for the
radiologists to read and
interpret and so the data sets as
they're
acquired clinically are matched to the
clinical question
if a person has just been ruled out for
a stroke
they're going to get a very fast very
rough scan because
strokes show up really well on these
scans
and so it the minutes that you might
take to get a better answer
will be potentially lost brain or date
more brain damage
when the real need is to get the person
quickly into the suite
where better imaging is available but
they'll have it as they are already
doing
an intervention to save the quality to
save that person's brain by opening a
clot or
stopping a hemorrhage or whatever
they're doing and so
the variability in the quality of the
scans is quite high depending on the
question being asked
if you're going in for a pre-surgical
mapping for an epilepsy
problem you might have super high
resolution because they're looking for
these tiny little cortical dysplasias
for example
so on the subject level very rarely is
any data
normal because no one is getting scanned
because they're normal
they're not they're getting scanned
because they're trying to rule out a
problem
but sometimes there aren't problems and
it's very reassuring to the patient and
the clinician that they didn't find the
problem and they look for something else
in a different way and so some of the
there are a few scans in the
box that are healthy and not and and
don't have brain pathology
and what you get out are those radiology
reports which are just a mere
fragment of a fraction of what's
available in the data
so when i here's a few just
representative you know images
randomly pulled out from our study just
to show you that the quality of the data
that's in there is really quite nice
and and um and there's lots of it and
all different kinds of it and it's
awesome
um but not all of it
so more often than in a research study
there will be poor quality because of
under sampling or motion or some kind of
a noise artifact
and i'm going to do it again on one of
my little digressions here to just show
you
um right now the way that we deal with
this is we just have to exclude these
studies because we can't use them
but there are some really exciting novel
approaches that are
on the horizon to mitigate this damage
or correct them afterwards
and work that's being done um partly by
some of the students and faculty
where i work and and many other places i
think probably around the world
um but i am going to teach you one tiny
bit about
mr physics which is just to say that um
that this work that's being done by my
uh but our
student nalini singh it's a really cool
work um
relies on the fact that in an at the
time that a patient is in the scanner or
the
scan data is being collected it's
collected in what's called frequency
space or k space
and a fourier transform is done to take
the data
out of k space and generate the image
in a typical mr workflow this happens
with one
pass it's done and then that's what gets
loaded into the radiology
archives so here is an experiment that
she has been working on
where she's actually using some machine
learning tools to
use both the k-space and the image space
data together
using a a deep learning
joint algorithm that takes those two
inputs the k-space image and the image
the k-space and the reconstructed image
and uses them
um to iteratively improve the quality of
the
out the final image that would be put
into the radiology archives for example
so what i'm showing you here in the data
set she uses for the
for this research she has what is called
ground truth which is a very high
quality beautiful scan
here down here at the bottom row you see
the frequency spectrum that's the k
space that
would have come off the scanner in the
little red box is a
a higher resolution and not a higher but
blow
focus in on this blood box is what's
shown in this little patch right here so
you can see more of the anatomical
detail and
when she takes the data set from the
same subject that's been corrupted by
this motion the person was moving their
head up and down
you can see that in the you know
especially easy to see in this higher
field
image that there is a lot of a lot a ton
of loss
of information um this difference line
here shows you the difference between
what's in the
high resolution ground truth and this
input image
here's what the case space looks like in
that corrupted image
so after it goes through her magic i'm
not even showing you the black box this
empty white space is her
algorithm what it spits out is an image
that looks very close to the ground
truth
you can see it higher resolution here
and in the difference image you can see
it's not perfect it's not exact but it
is considerably better
than what you uh see in in the original
image and so
this is you know future state because
this would have to be done at the
scanner when you saw the k space
available
uh the case-based data available um in a
standard workflow once it's
uh once the four-year transform happens
images are saved
the case-based data is thrown away and
so you can't work backwards
it's super cool work and uh there's a
citation if you want to learn more about
it
um similarly uh some of my other
colleagues this is work
led by eugenio igrisius uh he
takes a post-acquisition
approach and in this case uh it has the
possibility of actually
rescuing scans that were collected
enabling us to do more quantitative
morphometry
on that data or morphometric analyses on
that data
and this is maybe a little closer on the
horizon because we can use it on
existing scans so
again this is work that requires the
training of these deep convolutional
neural nets
where inputs they train a model using
good quality data and generate models
but then taking these
these poor poorer resolution or noisier
scans
as i'm showing you here is the inputs
into that trained
algorithm can output something that is a
little bit closer actually considerably
closer
to what ground truth would be
and this work is being done on a data
set
that is adney dataset so he has both
ground truth and
uh and the degraded images to work with
to make this a little more concrete um
here's what a scan this is a
an axial scan through the brain and it's
showing you the output of the software
tool called free surfer which is able to
both
segment cortical and subcortical
structures but also
make a very high resolution assessment
of the
cortical surface and the peel surface
and generate these nice surface maps
where you can see cortical thickness and
curvatures and things like that
um in data that's collected on say a
more typical clinical acquisition would
be thicker slices so this might
be seven millimeters instead of one
millimeter in
thickness here the algorithm doesn't do
the pre-surfer tool does not work so
well
but after he runs his um his
convolutional neural network
on that data and spits it out it does
bring it right back much closer to what
the original
what he the known ground truth in this
case this research data set shows
and so here quantitatively with respect
to that hippocampal volume i was
speaking of before when you look at the
how
accurate the reconstructed data is
or a lower resolution data is and how
accurately
it can find hippocampal volumes what he
has been able to show is that with his
nice algorithm the amount of error
goes from a seven millimeter scan goes
from the scattergram of these red dots
to this scattergram with the blue dots
making
the um average error dropping
from ten percent to three percent and
increasing
the effect size the result you're
basically that what that means is you
have a much greater
sensitivity to detect an abnormality
that is due
to the true anatomy anatomical problem
and so while this has been done on one
test data set this is again also
a recent report so early days lots of
exciting to look forward with that okay
back from those digressions about cool
tools that are going to help this and
help us in the future let me show you
how
how we do this at my institution and so
um we have at so i don't know how many
of you at your
centers have a clinical informatics um
infrastructure maybe you have the one
called itb2
or some other ones where you're able to
do a lot of um
research using the uh the
nicely archived clinical data where we
where i work um this is called partners
now it's uh we call it mgb for mass
general brigham
we have a really robust set of tools
where we can actually
find patient cohorts and work that i've
done collaboratively with
my colleagues in radiology and this
group's team
as well as dan marcus at washu
we designed and built a module plug-in
to it
that allows us to actually pull those
medical image data out
so reminding you of this slide i showed
you a little earlier
um the rpdr tool is things you know
allows us to pull out these
demographics about the patient and their
accession numbers and the radiology
report and the medical record numbers
and all that stuff
whereas the b2b2 tool allows us to
actually go in and query and retrieve
from the packs the actual image data
so how does it work you are
credentialed in here's my colleague sean
who is the
nico my co-developer in arms for
developing this capability he is the
the visionary behind this whole our pdr
infrastructure here
but the um this is a basically a query
front end
for a big database a huge database with
something like
six or seven million patients worth of
records in it
and you know i don't know how many
hundreds of millions of
pieces of information it sits in front
of but you basically just
click on little folders that
represent the information you're
interested in to drag
over and submit a query that is the
equivalent to you designing your cohort
experiment so you can
choose a cohort based on a diagnosis a
set of diagnostic codes or on a set of
procedure codes or sort of lab values
you can include or exclude them you can
restrict by age groups you can do all
sorts of very
very sophisticated analysis analyses to
generate a query and you don't
even need an irb at this point what
you're doing is just trying to
understand
how many what the sample size is that
would meet your criteria
and you know kind of does it break out
demographically to be what you want
because once you've jet you generate the
query that
represents the cohort you're interested
in you click this request detailed
button
detail data button and actually that was
an older slide an older version
now we actually so that's this is the
same slide
that i had just showed you but now in
our newer more enhanced version
the in addition to requesting the
detailed data which would just
be when i told you rpdr splits out we
have another button that says request
those
uh this is how you get your me to b2
workbench that stands for medical
imaging informatics bench to bedside me
too me too i want my
images is how i named that thing um
so this is where you uh you click this
button in order to put in your request
for the brain imaging data so
this tool works really nicely because
you know if you are getting your
images because of a query it works just
fine but let's just say that you have an
ongoing collaboration with a
set of research colleagues who already
know things about your
studies so for example in the work i'll
be showing you shortly
some of my neuroradiology colleagues
have been curating lists
of healthy normal babies and
and children because they needed them
for teaching cases
to teach the radiology residents so when
they would come across that rare once in
a while
person who actually had a child or maybe
who had a healthy
uh who turned out to be healthy and not
have anything bad happen
like an example of somebody who a baby
who had accidentally fallen in a
swimming pool
and and and was lifted out and they were
worried that you know they might have
not
um might have hurt themselves might have
been scanned and then
we had years of follow-up to say they
were fine for example that would be the
kind of thing that we might find
um we had that list uh we had a list of
cases we got that way
so you can put that list in also and
then you put in a request
for your me to b2 workbench and what's
really important about how we built this
is that
access to both the rpdr data and the me
to be to image
acquired images is through um
is managed in a way that's hipaa
compliant in order
to keep a log at all times of under what
irb
by what which investigators accessed
which data sets
um and they're all audit logged and we
keep track of all of that information to
be able to report out
once the person has their workbench
they log in and through a series of
steps they
find the they sort of have to fine-tune
here's where searching
in the radiology data there's a little
bit of work to be done there to find the
actual sequences and the studies that
you want
and you transfer those out for you to
work with
there's a citation right here teaches
you all about how we built this meet 2b2
workflow
and actually has the link to it's an
open
open source code so on the
i2b2 wiki and the community pages
there's actually a project for us and
so any of your sites that have itb2 that
you
might would like to use this kind of
software you can
it isn't we are already updating it um
locally so if you have any questions
reach out to me and i will
happily talk to you more about it if
you're interested in knowing how to use
this tool and what it takes and how to
do it
there's really detailed tutorials on our
help page which is open
this is not behind our firewall anybody
can see it
and we'll walk you through exactly how
how you use this tool to pull your data
down
so that was the how you get to the data
but now let me show you
some of the studies that we have done
with some of this data that we
began working on in about 2015
um as we were pulling the data down
maybe even a little bit before that
and then even more recently and this is
really work that could only be done with
the vision of my colleague
ellen grant who sort of saw this whole
arc
of what i'm about to share with you in
her mind's eye and it's been a
real pleasure being on this ride with
her and a lot of the work has been done
by yang
i'll show you more as we go okay
so for this and this is work that you
will be able to find at the reference
but i just showed you how you can use
the rpdr tool
to query and find scans and so we used a
combination of the
query tool as well as our data list and
we identified
about 2871 scans
where we knew that they had had a brain
mri scan done
and we knew that they were between the
ages of zero and six years of age at the
time the scan was done the brain never
eye was done
now one of the tricks here was that
because ellen is a
neuroradiologist extraordinaire she was
the one who had actually set up the
protocols for all baby brain mri
and she had included a particular
sequence and we knew
that um one of the other criteria we
used this the scan had been collected
after i think 2006 because that's when
um she very much before others were
using diffusion-rated imaging she
was one of the pioneers of it she got
the protocol
set up and run um and perfected so that
it did the best possible job and where
a single protocol would actually work
nicely
across the ages of zero to six and so
over the many years since
the only only very minor changes to that
protocol happened
like when they would upgrade a scanner
or the scanner software but the basic
procedure was continued
all through those years and so we had a
very coherent code
data set to begin with so we imported
those scans from the packs to our local
workstation
and then because we didn't have any
tools that would help us get rid of
the corruption that i was showing you or
other kinds of you know
loss because of the data um we lost only
in this case it's about not quite 50 of
the data which is
an incredibly small loss
most other studies that you might be
going after to get
good data you'd have a much higher loss
at this point
but we had a very good throughput
because we knew how to ask the right
question
of the data that was available so
collaborating with your local
neuroradiologist is really key
okay so then once we had gotten all of
those scans we
um we had clinician scientists and nurse
practitioners
reviewing nut and then our imaging
scientists
reviewing both the adc scans themselves
those are quantitative
apparent diffusion coefficient scans and
also looking into the ehr we have
under our irb we had permission to not
only download the data but to go into
the medical records to be able to see
finer details because our pdr doesn't
have every detail of every patient in it
and some of the details you need to look
in this pediatric data set
we had to look up on our own and we use
the redcap database to collect all that
kind of information in
and after carefully reviewing we got
we had to screen out um in this case
we're looking
just for the healthy normative ones we
screened down to about 705 potential
cases that
that might work well for us and then um
again through the uh the this was just
looking to make sure that the scans were
normal enough
and then we had to do additional medical
chart review on those cases
to confirm that for several years
afterwards
a minimum of three years that the
patients did not develop
any neuropsychiatric abnormalities to
make sure that the image data that we
were calling
normative was indeed reasonably
representative of normal
brain functions and structure and that
got us down from 705 to 201
no again surprise that people who are
imaged are imaged for a reason
for clinical reasons that are you know
where you are
interested in finding out or you have a
clinical
clinical suspicion that there's
something wrong with the brain
and even though at this point the the
radiology reports were read as normal
or normative that meant that the
radiologists on their own could not
detect abnormalities
it doesn't mean that they weren't there
it just means that this particular study
did not reveal it it was not sensitive
to reveal it and that's really
you know sort of a heads up i'll come
back to that
um way that is telling you something so
if you're losing 500 scans because
people do
end up having abnormalities that you can
tell already by the ages of
three years old then maybe there is some
signal there that isn't
being captured and it's a commercial for
what i'm going to tell you in a few more
minutes
so getting down to the 210 we finally
have nice clean data
that we can use to generate some atlases
which i'm going to tell you about again
right now and and use those in various
ways
to help us help the clinicians do better
make better use of this data so the
question is how do you
generate the once we generate those
addlesses
how do we do good work with them
and use them in ways that are really
meaningful and so
um when
a research scientist on their own would
go out and want to think about how do i
generate these different brain atlases
across these different ages
they might recruit a patient in and
study them repeatedly over
over the periods of time so you could
have longitudinal data which gives you
the most sensitivity to detect
change over time but then you're limited
by your cohort size
and you can only generalize to people
like the ones that you scanned
if you're interested in the span that
goes from zero years of age to six years
of age
also the obstacle of scanning repeatedly
in that age
age over that age span is is very
challenging there are some good data
sets out there and people working very
nicely with them
but the approach that this data allows
us to do is a very different one
where across time we aggregate
clusters of patients again no two
patients were used
one of the reasons another reason that
the numbers dropped as i was showing you
in the
in the previous seating slide is
sometimes there were repeat images on
the same subject so
they might have been studied being
studied longitudinally for clinical
reasons
but we only use them once in our data so
that we didn't have any biases
and so every single age we have a cohort
of patients
that are the same age and we can
generate what an average what a mean
is of a different group each different
time
the value of this is that first of all
it's feasible you can do it and
and the costs of uh you save a lot of
money not having to recruit and scan
and you're also getting a better
exemplar of what an average population
might look like
so i'm going to spend a minute on this
slide just
to say this was something we actually
were able to do in the early days
some of our very first efforts with this
data
this is probably back in like 2014 maybe
um where every one of these circles is a
different
scan result from a different individual
baby
or child this is the data platter from
the first about 800 days of life
so very early on and where there's
colored markers and lines those are
cases where an individual actually had
that longitudinal imaging going on
and a couple things i want to illustrate
here so we had to be able to
skull strip and and somewhat normalize
the data to be able to do this and also
you know strip away the csf so that we
could get what is called a
whole brain adc map so this is averaging
across all the voxels in the brain the
whole brain
and this wba whole brain adc measure
and what's plotted what you see is how
in the very earliest days it's high and
then it starts to come down lower which
you can sort of appreciate here in that
it's
brighter and getting darker one of the
key things
to notice is that this signal intensity
is not the adc
is not homogeneous over the whole brain
it does vary anatomically and so the
spatial localization of the value is
really important
and what um when we were first gathering
this the the first
uh effort ellen had told me she was
interested she said we should be able to
find in this data
a gradient from posterior to anterior
because
this drop happens earlier in the back of
the brain than the front of the brain
one of the features that makes this data
so
hard for clinicians to read and
interpret is that these changes are
happening
so rapidly especially in these early
days of life
so interpreting what is normal healthy
changes due to aging
and what changes are due to a
pathological event
is really hard to interpret and that
is part of the motivation for the work
that we are doing
so i mentioned that i'd show you a
little bit more about how those atlases
are created
so taking those 201
total uh data sets we divided them bend
them into
age bins the first two weeks of life the
second through fourth
second quarter third quarter fourth
quarter year two three four five six
and in each of those uh
cohorts there were enough cases that we
could
um here here are all the 13 case the 13
different babies that were used for
the youngest age atlas
they were skull stripped and put into
register and signal normalized
and then an atlas was generated that
generated the mean
adc at every single voxel as well as a
set of standard deviation measures
and here are those atlases this this is
the
one for right here the the mean
uh this is just showing the mean of the
adc values
over the brain in the coronal sagittal
and axial views
and this is for each one of those
different atlases from one to two weeks
up through
year six the way it's windowed here it's
a little hard to appreciate the subtle
differences
um but i what i will tell you is that
when we published this paper
um it contributed tremendously to the
literature because
many people have been trying to gather
this data and there were bits and pieces
in the literature
reported here and there but ours was the
most comprehensive that covered this
whole time frame
um i'm gonna do my normal uh
my well-deserved pitch to my colleagues
who make this
this resource available
that hosts the nitric website which is a
wonderful
neuroimaging resource for finding all
tools
all software all data sets go there if
you need anything to do with brain
imaging if you don't know about it you
should know about it everybody should
know about it
but this is where ian posted the
software for how to make an atlas like
this and
this is where those atlases are actually
released in case you want them
and here's the most recent work it took
until just
this past year to get published so at
first this is hard and second radial
neuroradiologists are really busy
but i want to call your attention to the
fact that this is actually published
in the general radiology this is the
journal that the radiologists use to
help them advance their clinical
practice
and what they by actually getting our
study into that journal which actually
came with a
a really nice um
an editorial that said not something
about not for the faint of heart
because they appreciated how much work
was done to be able to uh
quantify this information like not
everybody can do this be careful
um but i want you guys to know that you
can do this uh
and that and that this is a really
valuable contribution to make
and so um by getting it into this
audience
we are able to show uh on
both a region by region
uh way and also voxel by a box we'll
show you in a minute
um how the brain matures over this age
range and to provide some quantitative
metrics for what that looks like
in these adc maps that radiologists can
use to help them benchmark their reads
and so here are those atlases that i had
just shown you
and here are these beautiful
segmentations which yangming was able to
make happen because he he was able to
use these
these atlas transforms to bring a
segmentation atlas into this space
and transform it into younger younger
ages
typically these atlases require way more
sort of detail in the primary image data
to be able to find these anatomical
features
and these abc maps they're very blurry
it's tough to see this kind of detail
and so
having a tool that is meaningfully
segmenting these multiple regions
is incredibly useful because it allows
you to do something like this
which is to plot region by region how
the adc changes over age where let me
walk you through this
set of histograms over here
what you see here is plotted these are
the adc values so you can
this is flipped axis from what i was
showing you on the plot my very first
one where i was showing that little bit
of longitudinal data in our
and our and our cohort but here is
plotted the percentage of voxels
in a particular roi um the roi here the
region of interest here
is the whole brain so this is like that
same whole brain
histogram and um and now it's broken out
across the ages so starting at two you
know the
the youngest uh this is these are the
highest values so you can see this is
sort of like
watching the the the the data come down
in that histogram here in that in that
plot that i showed you
now you're seeing the histogram move
towards these lower and lower values
but you're also seeing something really
interesting it's not completely smooth
and you're starting to see some little
bumps here which tell you that there may
be
different some hint of that anatomical
variability
about when different structures mature
and so that's what's in these
other plots here so each of these
numbers corresponds to one of these
different plots
and each of those numbers is a different
brain region and what you're but again
we're showing
the changes in um at each of the
different ages over time
and you can appreciate those which show
a slower
rate of um of maturation
along the scale compared to those that
show a much steeper
change and so this kind of information
is quantitatively useful to a
radiologist
as they are moving around in the space
and trying to get a grip
on what they should expect to see in
their data
here's a kind of a prettier way to look
at this with 3d
mapping of the same data where what
you're looking at is sort of the
evolution
of how this changes and finally with a
with a lot of really elegant uh image
processing capabilities we can actually
visualize that
occipital to frontal
wave of maturation that's seen in this
in this adc
signal chain adc signal
so i just really lovely so let me just i
only have a little bit more time let me
show you
um another clinical application of this
work
um so
when babies are born who have had
basically a normal pregnancy
everything is great and fine something
happens right around the time of birth
and a full-term infant is born where
there for uh
there are many many this is a this is
kind of a grab bag term
for what are many many different reasons
why a baby might not have enough oxygen
or blood to their brain which causes
brain damage
it sadly occurs relatively often
and now we're starting to have much
better treatments for example they
figured out that they put the little
baby in a cooling they cool the baby's
temperature slightly
put them in these little cooling caps
they can slow down metabolism they can
slow down
um the damage that's occurring and help
the baby to recover and
and save a lot of brain but when this
happens
it's not uncommon for there to be
long-term outcome
um problems uh neuro deficits of many
different kinds
and so when the clinicians are
and parents are trying to decide on the
best possible care for a baby and for
them
you know for their family one of the
tools that they use to understand what's
going on is to get one of those brain
mris just like i showed you
and it's part of clinical it's
clinically required
and again they are using those exact
same acquisitions that i showed you
those really good quality acquisitions
that have been stable and not just at
our site but across
the country and the world it is standard
that they use these
these brain mris to help predict
outcome long-term outcomes and there is
some amount of agreement but and it does
help and they do
contribute and use the data but there's
a lot of variability both within a
single reader like the same clinician
reading the same study you give it to
them on other days and other times
they may not even get the same answer
out but very much between
raiders or different experts and so even
when people
have a lot of experience doing this it's
hard for them to read these cases
consistently and so
what you know i've now taught you about
those adc maps and uh in
hie the hypoxic ischemic encephalopathy
the the damage shows up as lower adc
values
okay and so sometimes it's really easy
to see and in this case
this is a healthy example um age match
to this clinical example
and probably all of you can make out
easily those lesions that are
that you know that are not tough to to
read where there's damage
there are most cases are far more
challenging than that
and if i asked you to show me where on
this scan or on this scan
there were abnormalities it's a much
tougher tougher job
and so how do we do that we can take our
atlases and so here
you know is that adc atlas from those
little babies from zero to two weeks of
age
and here is one of those scans from a
baby with a patient who has
been diagnosed with hie when we
set those voxels and your eye can
probably make out um
i'm seeing a thing that says my
internet's unstable hopefully you can
still hear me okay
uh maybe your eye can make out this
darker
area here and maybe your eye can make
out
somewhat this little darker areas here
and here maybe you weren't as able to
appreciate
some of these areas that were brighter
than they than they
they might be expected to be and so
um we're doing the work now to um
to map how carefully and how accurately
these uh this this algorithm might
by the algorithm being taking the atlas
and comparing it to the
um to the norm to the patient's own scan
how often uh our atlases will detect
the same thing that a radiologist here
two different radiologists
manually marked up this patient's adc
map
and here you can see how closely the
algorithm will compare to that
so this is one line of work that's going
on right now
another way that we can use this is to
generate atlases from
the scans of the babies who have the
abnormalities
and get some sense of information about
which are the most commonly found
areas that are abnormal and or which
regions and or networks of regions are
important for yielding the kinds of
clinical pathology that we see
so finally just a quick sort of vision
of what a futures
future positive might look like if this
work
continues or things like it then when
the radiologist is in a radiate in the
reading room
and they have a patient's data they're
looking at what they might also
pull up in front of them would be a
reference atlas that would tell them so
they could mouse over the two different
ones and get a sense of
what values should be there and what do
i actually have here if i think i see
something abnormal
and also potentially even a beautifully
color-coded map that shows them
where to double check more carefully and
it's still their choice what to make
of this and whether that is information
that's useful or not and they have a lot
more information they use it's not
to replace the radiologist this the name
for this is computer computer-aided
diagnosis you give the you use
computational tools to help the
clinicians to
um to do their work and so that's the
kind of thing we're hoping to see
but maybe even before that that it would
be useful in classrooms for teaching
people so
i will pause there for more questions i
will just
give a huge shout out to uh ellen
and to yang ming my friend steve the
fabulous teen that makes the
um our our informatics tools work
and sing at home there's lots more
people and
and good funding and i'm really blessed
to have had great uh
trainees that worked with me from
epfl and i missed them i wish they were
still back in my lab
it's a great team and uh thank you for
your time and for listening
randy thank you so much for that that
was uh really
exciting to see all that neural imaging
work and some of those studies are yeah
absolutely not for the faint of heart
that's a lot of work
um i have a few questions for you um
this goes back to the earlier part of
your talk where you're talking about
some of the
uh image quality variation that we
see in kind of clinical studies and i'm
curious um
do you feel that there is a
responsibility of for
like researchers to include or maybe
even educate
the mri scanner texts techs as part of
the research
enterprise to make sure that they
understand the value of
getting a relatively standardized data
even if they need to customize it a
little bit for different sizes of head
you know what i mean so i would say that
at most places this is um
our our teams here at least at our
hospitals
are so with the program they they at the
so we have a pretty virtuous cycle that
the um
the research teams that develop and
enhance our new
um like because we are a big research
site for
for siemens and for other other
manufacturers where we are always
we are evolving and advancing the
different kinds of technologies for
later clinical for with a direct eye on
clinical translation
so our our teams of researcher
physicists algorithm developers whatever
are also
very closely parked in our clinical
scanners
helping to support the training and that
transition and that translation
our neuroradiologists are our partners
in all of this
and everybody's pulling towards the best
possible data in the you know in the
best possible care of the patients and
so
i think that there is uh
i i think that if you quietly took any
one of our mr techs off in a corner and
had
you know a kind and supportive
conversation with them you would come
away
feeling like they really do know and
they really do care and they really
aren't doing their best
that's that's super great i think it's
really important to keep those
conversations going we
work a lot on on having like grand
rounds and having
case conferences and doing things like
that there's a lot of in-servicing
communication is really important um and
and i'm sure there's outliers but
it it you know it's a team's you know
all of this is a team
sport you shared with us uh some of the
really interesting uh databasing
developments that you've done
there at mgh and i'm you're very
familiar with
uh things that are large-scale neural
imaging
data archives like the human connectome
project and various others of that
spirit
where everybody you know from the
centers around the country are
collecting
all the same protocol and exactly the
same kind of scanners and and all that
so they're all very uniform
um the clinical data on the other hand
like for example i have
very often interested in traumatic brain
injury data
but getting that data there there's very
few places to go
um to find it there are a few but i'm
curious if you have any other
databases that you are aware of and want
to share
information about for our for our
listeners
so um that you mean that are outside of
the research realm that might be like
clinical databases
absolutely yes so here's what i would
say
i'm gonna guess that almost every major
hospital and academic health care system
has in their packs some pretty valuable
traumatic brain images already
and that because that is i think
i'm going to go out on a limb here i'm
going to guess that
brain imaging is one of the um like for
those little babies with
hie i'm going to guess that brain
imaging is
almost always done and and so traumatic
brain injury is a big umbrella term like
hie there's a lot of different reasons
why people have it car accidents
football
you know getting shot in the head huge
variation in what that means
and so we have come a long way in
developing
imaging sequences that are very useful
for
evaluating many of those different
sources of brain
trauma and so there are like
susceptibility weighted imaging for
example comes to mind which is you know
was not a very big
sequence you know when i started this
baby brains work but is now i think
fairly bread and butter on on most uh
acquisitions that have that as the
clinical question
i would venture to guess if i were i'm
not
i'm kind of risk averse but i think i
would i would happily put money on a bet
that if you had colleagues at various
big medical centers
who had neuroradiology friends they
could talk to and found out were they
doing these sequences for those patients
that you could put together a team of
people and a team of sites
and find this data and work with it and
even though
on the research side we harmonize so
explicitly for the every little detail
of the
acquisition there is a layer of
harmonization that is happening across
all scanners everywhere because they're
you know they're siemens there's ge
they're philip there's there's only a
few flavors
and each of them only have a few kinds
and each of them only have a few
different software versions and each of
them
and if they don't have like our research
licensing and special
agreements with the manufacturers
they're using the bread and butter
sequences that are everywhere
and those tend to be quite good and so
you probably could find some really
awesome opportunity there
that's great i was really i wrote down
this
question before you kind of got to it
there at the end about
um uh sort of looking at sort of
clinical syndrome atlases
and comparing sort of you know patients
that you might have
against clinical atlases to help
clinicians make inferences about where
to look and it looks like and i wrote
this down thinking
it wouldn't be cool to have a tool that
does that and then you went and showed
one so
that's fantastic but i wanted to follow
up with that is that
what role is there for data scientists
to help develop tools like that
um what are some low hanging things that
could get people excited about
making those kind of tools i don't know
what makes this specific to a data
scientist i
i mean yes we should all be doing this
like come i
um so i i suppose at the data
so data scientist is a new term for me
because everybody i know i consider a
data scientist so when you ask me that
question in that way
um can you give me a little bit more
guard rails about what your
what kind of answer you want because yes
if you
have access to data with
you know admiral you know a cohort with
some abnormalities that are quantitative
that you can find then
there are tools to start working with
that so what do you what are you asking
me
certainly well i usually like to think
of data science as much
more broad than machine learning for
example
to say that somebody who does machine
learning as a data scientist
is sort of you know it's neither here
nor there really
because of course they do but on the
other hand if you wanted to say apply
machine learning techniques and develop
tools around that
um what else might they need to know in
order to get started doing that
so so if you're working in this
particular little niche domain
kind of thing and you wanted to build
those bridges things that help a lot are
being
facile with working in the field of
clinical informatics so being able to
know and understand
what are the warts and whistles in
working with ehr data so missingness and
sparsity and like when
absence of information doesn't mean that
something's not there i mean you it
takes it's a whole mindset to know how
to do
data science on electronic healthcare
record data
so if you're and a lot of this work is
best
served when you have a combination
of the medical imaging and the detailed
clinical information
so for example with hie work
while we none of that data that we
needed for doing our outcome measures or
to do some of the you know next layers
of work that we'll do where we look at
factors that influence outcome or more
details of
care decisions all of that was gathered
by going through the clinical records
and pulling it out
mining it out
you wouldn't be able to get anywhere
near as much meaning out of those
atlases
the atlas application to those uh
cases that have problems without knowing
those clinical contexts the clinical
context is
really really important for interpreting
the results and so
data scientists who can have enough uh
biomedical knowledge to comfortably you
know
maneuver around in that space and
interpret and understand what's there
or at least to be able to ask all the
good questions so that they have their
domain expert to
you know to support them in that way is
really
important um i think on the medical
imaging physics side understanding how
variations you have to know which data
you can merge in which you can't
and so um for example with that the tool
i was showing with jojenio where he was
doing that post-processing for being
able to take the
the thicker clinical slices and then um
turn them into
isotropic voxels that would run through
freesurfer
you have to know which you know things
like
you can't use a post contrast scan
because contrast introduces a a change
in the contrast properties of all the
tissue
and so the algorithm is completely
different than in pre-contrast scans
um you have to understand that the the
way that the free surfer works
on that data the the anything that it
would output in terms of like a cortical
thickness measure
is very suspect it's not really
trustworthy the way i say a hippocampal
volume could be
and there's an interaction between
knowing
the mr physics and how the image is
generated and made and the
properties of the t of the scan and then
how those algorithms run and so
there are there's great it's really good
to do this in teams where because it
takes a lot of different people to know
all the different parts
i think that's an important part is that
uh all of this and it's one of the
reasons i enjoy this is because it is a
team sport and
it really does take a a collection of
people with different and
interlocking skills to be able to deal
with the
type of data the amount of data and all
the nuances you just described so
absolutely well uh dr golub let me thank
you so much for
joining us today and sharing your
amazing work um
i really appreciate it thank you once
again
and uh to all of our people who've been
listening in today thank you so much
um everyone enjoy your weekend and we'll
see you next week thank you again randy
my pleasure bye